(rockets blasting)
(soft music)
- [Felicia] The events
of the past 24 hours
have been a serious test
for Israel's new government.
You saw militants in Gaza,
launching incendiary balloons,
these are basically
balloons that are on fire
and aimed at setting ablaze
Israeli farms close to the Gaza border.
That was in response to a rescheduled
March through Jerusalem, where there were
some clashes between
Palestinians and police
leaving dozens injured.
(upbeat music)
(crowd chanting)
(speaking in a foreign language)
(soft music)
I think both sides do have
some incentive not to escalate
but of course,
if another cycle of escalation
spirals out of control
with both sides trying
to prove themselves,
it could be a very volatile
and dangerous chapter.
(crowds chanting)